through from the beginning of when you
wrote your book to being here tonight
what time frame are we talking about how
long was that process was pretty fast
okay and then how did you present the
book for adaptation I guess for for Luke
to write it or how did that whole
process turn Luke and then that I said
to Cecil fields take you through the
journey that I went through
that you sort of get from reading of
books I came back to where it started
and do the train journeys and to
ensuring every places that are going to
be covered in potential strategy because
I think you know if I didn't have that
thing would be clean so doing this for
me lion has been my favorite narrative
for the year and I'm not just saying
that because you're in front of me here
I really am excited to to tell others
about it I have the whole package is
beautiful with the music and everything
for you I'm wondering what's been an
inspiring film that's touched your life
as lioness touched mine it could be from
any any year doesn't have to be this
movie it's very relevant actually a lion
and this other movie the non grata
it's called The Joy Luck Club
I don't know compared to them yes we're
particularly where I'm standing now is
the end of the movie that's you know I
meet my mother and it's very it's very
touching to me I have a very soft spot
for that movie but but it's an amazing
movie that I saw at a young age and
remember it's still together so when you
saw that film and then when you begin
working with Luke Davies on the
screenplay
did you want people to come away with
the same feeling or a similar feeling or
really because it was about your life
you weren't able to really remove
yourself because if that movie impacted
you did you want others to be impacted
as well in the same manner against Luke
to make that variation in situation
we've got
I guess I guess that's such a people to
point in the movie as world and you know
that particular reading together our
mother and mother and I think the way
that Luke has done it is really really
amazing and and he's you know really I
wanted to get down to the grassroots in
regards to those particular and more
specifically that particular scene
because apparently that was the first
scene shot but you know a lot of people
what book for you is uh been
instrumental in the creative process and
writing for you like personally what
what book on writing creativity it's a
llama because today I've already been
really waiting and in sometimes raining
bombs you know it's sort of beauty
magazines of Cosmopolitan if you have
three button yeah this is look this is
I'm a first-time author and I'll never
remember and
you know went from being sort of into
industrial retail sales to just learning
English you know
to join this journey and all the Sun
becoming becoming an author by being
asked to write a memoir now I understand
you're working with your mom on a second
book is that right or oh I another video
little birdie told me yeah yeah we are
look we're about to start the prequel a
long way home this which is so much
really made coming to the point
just prior to me which most of them do
the B to do with their mothers which is
me which is my adoptive mother's mantra
promoter and also one more lady with
just serve our Syrians theme for the you
know one of the humanitarian side just
help others
and nothing you know I'm just getting
goosebumps just talking about it because
it is so it is so unique to have you
know women from oceans apart all wanting
to do one thing is that so called a
child
giving all her another chance well I
could stay here all night and talk to
you but I know you have to go one last
question and that is for people of an
adult age who have a childhood that
either they don't remember or there's a
lot of unanswered questions and they're
adults
what would you recommend to them on
either going home or trying to find out
more about their own history so that
they know who they are a sense of
themselves I'm not too sure but it's you
know for me it was finding closure and
everyone and for them I think it's
listening to your heart and listening to
your dreams really because that's where
it was to me you know in a nutshell
capsulated and if they if they
in such a way in their shoulders that
order to sue because certificate and you
know
but give it abandoned tapes and at least
try to give an sis enclosure to
something that you know you can get
access to because well thank you and
good luck tonight thank you sir